let's ask what's up buddy
hello Rich can you hear me yeah
I'm from Germany and I almost read your
book but
um during I say almost because before I
finished I read some of the red flags to
my mom and she took the book away from
me
but uh oh that's not a big problem I'm
14. you're 14. okay so your mom took
your book away okay yes but that's not a
problem I will find it online and then I
will buy it then I can read it again I
mean finish why did she why did she take
the book away after you went through the
red flag chapter with her yeah I mean I
told her that some of the red flags that
uh I've read in the book that I've seen
her
do that as well uh I mean that's why she
took it away she didn't like hearing
about those being in her personally yes
yes but uh you know I'm not married yet
obviously but uh um you know I would
like to ask you how I maybe could handle
better the relationship with my mom
because I have four years more to go
um what about your Dad what's the story
with him
um she told me that he died in a car
accident when before I was born but now
I don't even believe her that
huh okay
um and you're 14.
yes
all right
um look
you're gonna have
it sounds to me like you're gonna have
some issues with your mom or that you're
already having them right now you say
that you don't believe the story that
she told you about how your dad died
yeah I mean she she never really talks
about it but um you know
um she just says he died and that's it
do you think he's still alive
um I don't know I mean could be I I
don't know it yet what what were the red
flags that upset your mom that you
pointed to you said that there were some
in the red flag chapter do you recall
which ones uh they were
um I mean there were a lot of them all
actually so let me go through the 20 red
flags daddy issues feminists unhappy and
unlucky competes with you has a lot of
men from her past as she keeps around
she's bad with money she's violent she's
jealous she likes to party too much
tattoos and piercings been with a lot of
guys uh single mom well that's her uh
seeking validation online is a sugar
baby is a pathological liar has baby
rabies throws Hissy Fits it sounds like
she throws Hissy Fits if she's taking
her book away yeah I mean she she I
don't know but she goes out with a lot
of guys but I don't know more about that
um she is active online and yeah she she
likes um the the way of the feminist way
of of thinking like many many people in
Germany okay so let me ask you a
question do you do you fight do you like
to go to a dojo do you do any thing
boxing kickboxing Krav Maga Jiu Jitsu um
I mean I I've I've been training
football but now you know in in the last
couple of years with Corona and
everything my mom is not allowing me
anymore to go she because she says it's
dangerous what are you an adult in
Germany is it 16 or is it 18
it's 18 18. so you're basically living
under her roof for the next four years
you don't know if your dad's around if
she made up The Story You're gonna look
my friend you're gonna have some
difficulty over the next few years
you've got to find something on the
outside as an outlet for you where you
have strong masculine presence you need
a masculine Mentor
um ideally if you can join a dojo learn
boxing learn karate learn kickboxing
just get into a fighting sport some kind
of combat Sport and spend time with an
instructor spend time with other guys
there you need an outlet because
you're in a position right now where
she's completely
look man
I mean I I've I've seen that I've I've
seen it that also in your book you've
been talking about the fighting I've
also tried that to talk about with with
my mom but she doesn't allow me the the
only thing that I really can do is
online do you have a job no I don't have
a job but I'm doing pretty good online
on my own uh what do you mean online on
your own do you have a source of income
yeah I'm I'm doing pretty good actually
I have some crypto I have some crypto
and I also am in in in in the business
with some Affiliates
um to my to my online channels okay I
don't have it's nowhere my face or
anything I just Market the products okay
and how much money do you make monthly
um I mean it's it's not really
um always the same but I would say like
here in Germany after taxes
um you know I get between maybe two and
five thousand Euros a month
is it possible for you to move out on
your own are you still too young to do
that no with with the laws here I'm not
allowed actually to do that
have you I mean somebody put this out in
the comments like if you ask relatives
about the status of your father just to
confirm
I only have my mom you don't have any
cousins no uncles
her parents are dead and she she was the
only child
she's the only child her parents are
dead she said your father died in a car
accident that your your father didn't
have any siblings you don't have any
aunts or uncles you don't have any
grandparents no actually from My
Father's Side to nothing I I just know
about the grandparents from from my
mother
but as I said there are that you know
dude you live in a bubble like like this
guy says over here like you live in this
like
you've you've got to find a way to
interact with men
that I have to go through it four more
years but I'm just looking for maybe
some advice how I can deal better with
it during these four years
um I'm telling you what you need to do
you need to find an outlet whether it's
a part-time job outside of the house
where you get to interact with other
people
um find something where men generally
operate
um think about some options for you
something like even if it's physical
labor dude like
construction uh trades apprenticeships
in any of those areas
uh just trying anything that like gets
you around other guys so that you get
some exposure because kids like you my
friend I've talked to lots of guys in
their 20s 30s 40s and 50s that describe
exactly your position right now at 14
and the longer you let you know yourself
live under the control of her thumb the
way that she's running you the harder
it's going to be for you when you're an
adult the sooner that you can get you
know put yourself in a position where
you can be around men and masculinity
and learn more you know there's more to
the world than just your mom's house and
her rule of the law the better off
you're going to be and I can't see why
she would protest you know with you
saying hey Mom you know I just want to
go and you know do something physical
like get a gym membership and lift
weights right you know go to a dojo and
learn how to fight like there's got to
be something that you can do that will
let let you get out of the house
on your own doing what it is you want to
do I mean she's out and about uh
partying or dating guys or whatever you
know that you said that she was doing
you've got to have the opportunity to do
these things for yourself right
okay thank you thank you for the advice
okay man good luck with that I will look
how I can do that thank you okay hey
guys I really hope that you enjoyed that
short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out